今年の縛りなしですか安心してください
しっかり準備しましたこんにちははじめ手帳ですね
新年の挨拶2021年明けましておめでとうございます
今ちょっとお仕事で東京に生きているんですけども安心してください車で来てこのよう
に車でもターゲットも接触月て大経でも家から出ずに生活しておりますので安心して
くださいやちょっとねぇ
東急くるの強いね怖いんですけども仕事できておりますので細心の注意を払っており
ますが人と接触しなければ大丈夫だと思ってるんであらゆる可能性を向上して気をつけ
て生活しております肇社長です強いけど2021年どんな年にしたいかと言いますと
もうほんとただがむしゃらに頑張るとしかなぁチャンネル登録者数1000万読み出し
て浸せだ
ふざけたいと思います本気でいただきたいと思います手段を選びます製錬所したら許し
てくださった人に迷惑かけたくありますいざ不本意ながらかけることもあるでしょうが
ごめんなぜも
動画楽しみますそんな一年にしたいと思っておりますのでよろしくお願い致しますで
去年の1年間のテーマ復帰の道がちょっともう少々お待ちくださいそしてもうなんか車
和紙張りいいじゃんっていうか貼ってきちゃってるっていうかなんか腹筋に感謝も縛り
じゃなかったんですよいままでなんか何か禁止とか何か食べちゃダメしてやってきたん
ですけど腹筋は縛れじゃなくて私はちゃんと戻してへと4倍にしたいと思うんですけど
も
今年の縛りはちょっとねほんとワンちゃん俺の人生を左右するね俺の人生を左右するん
ですけども多分あの生活に支障はないかなと思ってるんですけどちょっと怖いんです
けどまぁけどやってみようかなと思って決めましたもうタイトルにも全然あると思うん
ですけども
[音楽]
始めシャツを
今年は
[音楽]
ごはん食べません
あのごらんっていうかね白ご飯米だねあのー
僕コメ付キーなお米が大好きで知ってを込めないとホントどうか4歳からよごめん好き
なんですけど逆にそこを止めてみようかなと思いますねまぁ何でもご飯おいしいんです
けどもやっぱりなんかよく言われているのは同室が高いとか言われてるんでなんか本当
に金今ならかどうかってたまに音が労組が大きいでぐらいだと言われてるんですけども
まぁそんなどうでもいいね美味しい
ですこのご飯が美味しすぎて俺はもうねあの飯を食うときで絶対しローハンと書かない
とも嫌な暗いったごはんが嫌い
逆に人がいても絶対のご飯つけるんですよ枯れない人かもそんなあれもらいしないと俺
ちょっと厳しいですよなんだったらちょっと音ややなぁこそ人もそうだけどチョイ
ちゃんじゃないんですよそしても散乱したにがないとダメじゃないです私を取り巻く
生活における食べ物においてやっぱりご飯
白ご飯
あとは米っていうのは非常に欠かせない存在なのであえて笑ってああ
[音楽]
me
またそのドジでパンとか迷惑んですけどなので何で健康的ダメじゃ少ないと思います炭
水化物をやめるわけでもないから私の体を支えている食べ物
5箱目系をすべて抜く1年で処方います何が禁止になるんでしょちょっと考えてみよ
えっとまずオムライス無理でしょさあ
やだなお寿司もダメでしょうカレーライスもダメでしょチャーハンまとめ
牛どうもないでしょ本格定食のご飯もダメ
原作じゃないカツとご飯のキャベツでやっと一つのあの娘の参加型ができると思ってる
んでそこから子なんだろうと大きいなああああ
やばいねーでもあのでもあの
んやるしかないですよハートなってきてですよ他の皆さん想像してみてください1年間
我慢して食べた後の白子は死ぬぜコメットやっぱりおいしいですよねーの1年間が混ぜ
食べる俺ご飯を夢見て今年1年頑張りたいと思っておりますがおにぎりを食べる
ないんだやっぱレズっ子とドイツ語は棋士賞と堀は捨てる1月1日に木最後のご飯食べ
たんですけども何が描かれたのか
こちらをご覧くださいどうぞ1月1日2021年最後のご飯ですチーズ牛丼特盛です
いろんなのが思い浮かびました大江ナイスも好きだし本学と一緒に食べるご飯も好き
かねない人も大好きでそのすべてを超越した私を形成する食べ物それが
10 don aiff まっちーずいうのもいただきます
8 e 4 e
ん
俺は日本だ地であるがゆえに1年間米と別れし来年必ずコメ熊襲
神しれんっておきます
うまいっ
本当に夢を込めて
[音楽]
ん
ぬーん
ええん
[音楽]
ん
ふーん
ni
ああああああ
はいというわけでしヴィシー戦いになるでしょう非常に食べモードの制約がかなり
苦しい状況だと思うご飯ものと言ったら欠かせないしてると思うんですよなんだから
定食ともごはん脱ぎたら食べることになるからタント画面とが選べないお店だったら
痩せるんでちょっといろいろ健康的にはなるような気もしてます中で前年なんか淡青丸
富禁止とかじゃないんで極端に電気
が無くなるところもないと思うけども全然にご飯を食べなかったら1年かとう由梨香が
するのか見ていきたいと思います非常に厳しい戦いになると思いますが皆さんも知って
いるでしょう
この手の企画動くやらせないことオスマンないじゃあ食べたら絶対食べないから安心し
てください
俺の身の回りの人うを反映さとで俺があったら俺の食卓とがみてください必ずかんだ
ラズ1年間米を食べません
その分
ルードゥ
あった